three two one
hey what's up welcome back to my channel
i am super excited to introduce you to
an incredible property investor
his name is giuseppe over the last few
years he's put up a large property
portfolio
he is financially free and in this video
he's gonna be explaining exactly step by
step
how he has done it so that you can do
the same giuseppe welcome to the show
hello samuel thank you very much for
inviting me well it just happened you've
achieved so much over the last few years
um it's really great to see what you've
done and also where you're going you
know some of the deals you're working on
but why don't you start just by getting
a little bit of background
before you owned 12 houses and
financially free
uh tell me a bit about where you're from
how you got started in property
and how this all began yeah um i come
from italy i came in uk in 2008
uh doing my phd and then became a
university lecturer in scotland
in sterling and then as everybody i
would say
they go through the pain of not getting
enough salary at the end of the month
and too much month before the next
payday so i had to do something i had to
you know get another business something
else going on so that's
how i started to google how to get rich
yeah legally how to make money real and
then property came up
and i said property sounds like a game
for rich people only
not for me because i come from a very
humble background
but then i say well let's give it a try
so i started to get trained
watch youtube videos buy books etc and
that's how i bought
the first property now bear in mind i
didn't have money i only had 37 pounds
left in the bank at the end of the month
so i had a house and released equity
release equity from my
my house my residential house and then i
bought it i bought the first bite to let
that's great so i mean when we first met
about oh
four maybe four years ago now um a lot
of energy
not much money you say you had what 36
pounds
yes um so how did you how did you get
the money
to buy your first property what happened
what happened is i got educated i knew
i learned a new language like equity
release and i think is equity release
and then i realized that yeah is the
difference between
the value of your house and the
outstanding mortgage so that little bit
you can pull out
tax free basically and i did it i called
the bank i said do i have any equity in
the house and say yes you have 27 000
pounds that's it okay can i pull it down
pull it out and say yeah
so that's i've done this transfer and
bought the first
by two minutes so that money then so
basically you owned your own home
you didn't have a lot of cash but you
had some money tied up in your house
you realized that you actually could
pull that money out tax-free
and use that money to reinvest yeah so
you bought your first property
and what was this like around about 2018
2019 yeah 2018 uh 2017.
2017. yeah 2017. oh actually really was
full so
that 37 pounding back was august 2017
yeah i bought the first one in december
2017.
okay nice nice okay so that was your
first property
great nice what happened next next i
started to like it
i see that it works and the bite
at the back right was working really
well then i learned about service
accommodation and i turned that one into
service accommodation
and i got more bookings more money and i
could
get a deposit for the next one yeah
which was straight
serviced accommodation yeah so so
basically you went from
you know working your job having uh
what you thought no money to realize and
you did have a little bit of money you
refinanced
you bought a house you rented it out
short
short term that serviced accommodation
which is a much smarter way which we'll
get onto
um and then slowly sort of started
snowballing yeah
um talk to me a little bit about the
mindset because i know one of the things
that one of the reasons we get on so
well is because you know you're you
you're really aware that this is this is
literally 50
yeah the person 50 the technical skill
so you know you're you've always had an
upbeat personality you've always had
a positive mindset can do attitude talk
to me a little bit about
you know that and and and maybe some of
the challenge mental challenges that you
had going along and then
i want to talk about how you got
literally to 12 in the space of just a
few years
well it's simple samuel um if you don't
do it you don't change anything
yeah so if you want to change something
because you have a pain or you have
something inside you that says
you know i could do better then you
would stay the same
so the only the only way to go is
forward
and and that's what i did you know i
knew the other people were doing it so
that means it is possible so it was up
to me
if i wanted to make it work or not yeah
and also as well i think there's
you know you had 27 grand equity in the
house you didn't necessarily you weren't
even aware of that
a few years ago a lot of people might be
in that situation whereby they feel like
they've not got much money
but you've in space of a few years
you've accumulated a large portfolio of
12 properties
one of them is a rental rent yeah 11 of
them 11 of them you own
um financially free you've done this all
in
scotland um it's it's a remarkable story
you know and it for me it's really i
remember actually getting a facebook
message from you
when you listed your first property
on service accommodation and you're like
oh man it's happening the bookings
you know but now that's like a lifetime
ago yeah
the way you've moved on now people come
to you for advice
and you've got your own youtube channel
you're inspiring people you're sharing
um which is which is which is just
absolutely incredible how did we
first connect like what's the story of
how we first met
we met the first time was in a crash
course in manchester i remember was uh
2017 2018 yeah
and i didn't know anything about
property so for me was just
i was getting all the information from
as i say youtube i met you on youtube
and then i decided to come to the crash
course and then i bought other books uh
from other people as well
but that energy that uh knowledge you
know
seeing that this it is possible yeah
that will push me and remember i asked
you a question during the lunch break
probably you don't remember this i said
you were talking about agent moore
and i said well where i live uh they are
saturated with html license and the
currency is not giving any more license
so
what do i do and he said move to another
another city
i said that sounds so simple that's true
yeah sometimes we have problems we will
see
we perceive problems you know as
problems but
in actual fact there is a solution for
every problem yeah
so yeah that's so true and if you focus
on the problem
you're in scotland so i want to get a
bit i want to talk about some of the
differences i was going to say
challenges but not necessarily some of
the differences in scotland because you
what you've done is
all your deals are in scotland right um
but
um but you've got to find the solution
rather than finding the problem because
you can say
oh this doesn't work in scotland or this
isn't the same but actually what you've
done which is really smart
is you flip the cards and you've tapped
into all the advantages in scotland
you've got tenant buyers
you've got edinburgh i know you're not
in edinburgh but edinburgh in scotland
is
the best place for service domination in
the entire uk
so it's about finding the opportunities
um another really interesting
fact of the day is which i i find
amazing is you were
the exact same deal filing extravaganza
as anthony anthony who which is crazy so
you're kind of that same kind of era um
and and and just to just say because
i've said this to with anthony before
maybe
people don't believe it what happened if
you can remember with anthony
the bets that i gave him do you remember
that i think you offered him a thousand
pounds or something yeah
i'll give you a thousand pounds to fix
your car and at the time
anthony a thousand pounds was a big deal
to anthony
but now anthony owns a castle you know
you've now got a really big portfolio
you're teaching others you're sharing
you're inspiring
and it's just like four years ago
i mean it's crazy what can what can
change in four years and i've
loved watching your journey stalking you
on facebook
seeing your deals go through you know
it's been an incredible journey
so okay um talk to me then scotland
england pros and cons go oh okay
that's a good question uh there are
differences of course
uh for example some duty uh three
percent in england and wales
four percent in scotland so for the for
the english
might be might sound a bit more
expensive to invest in scotland but then
at the same time
once you make an offer in scotland and
the house and
the the office is being verbally
accepted that's your house you know
you can complete on the house you don't
get gazant like in england
yeah so you have a bit more security uh
when you when you
when you're offering a property and the
pros and cons of that i guess is because
a lot of people complain in england they
say
i put an offer on it was accepted but
then someone came and outbid me and they
get annoyed
but it's like yeah but if it was a case
of you put an offer on
and then it was accepted and no one else
could come in and you had to buy it
you'd then be all scared about putting
the offer on which also is a
is a con in scotland i guess from a
buyer's perspective if you put an offer
forward
it gets accepted you sign you have to
buy it yeah
yeah another thing is flat for example
scotland uh they're all freehold you we
don't have leasehold
yeah which means you own the land where
it's built even if it's second floor it
doesn't matter
where's england that's never the case
yeah all flats are leasehold
also as well uh lease options yeah you
can't do this option
in scotland but it's called exchange
with delay completion which is kind of
similar principle
but rather than the option to buy at the
end of the term which is seven years ten
years whatever
you have the obligation to buy it so
that's the difference
one of the things you've done really
well with your portfolio because 12
houses
um you know i know people that have got
100 houses but you make more money
because they might have 100 houses they
could have 200 houses
but unless you maximize every property
right
now you've got a few of your properties
on service accommodation um but you've
also got
tenant buyers in some of your houses i'd
love to talk a little bit about that
so stop tell me why do you put a tenant
bar in your property and what does that
mean
right so i love this strategy rent to
buy is a strategy that
gives no hassle whatsoever to landlord
because that is one of the things you
know with all the eviction
ban it has been during lockdown you
could have
turned if they're not paying et cetera
this doesn't happen in rent to buy
because the tenants
have a different mindset different
mentality they know they're stepping in
a property that's going to be their own
property at the end of the term
again it can be five seven ten years
time you can agree at the beginning
you agree the price at the end the
purchase price
uh there's going to be at the end but
you agree today like at least option
and then they are responsible for
repairs maintenance
if they want to change a kitchen they
can do it if they want to change the
garden you can do it that's up to them
because it's their house
so they're paying you the rent but
they're paying you also a top up
now the top is just um it's a buildup of
the 10
of their deposit at the end of the term
okay which means
you can't touch the top up at all it's
in a different server account a client
account
but if they default on the rent and you
can you can get it they lose it
yeah if they damage the property they
lose it if they
complete at the end that's their deposit
10
for the mortgage it's genius because
it's basically like
a way of ensuring that the tenant is
incentivized
to pay the rent on time to look after
the property
but at the same time um you're still
getting your rent
they're buying the property but
presumably at a premium yes so you're
getting a premium sale
premium rent but from their perspective
they can call it home
yeah so it's a really really really good
strategy
um and and another thing you've done as
well with some of your houses you've
turned them to
um mini hotels service service
accommodation
talk to me about what is service
accommodation and why have you chosen
to rent out some of your properties as
mini hotels okay so the normal buy to
let
you rent uh to tenant and then it's a
long term uh
tenant the seventh accommodation is a
short term let and you rent
the the the house per night or the flat
department whatever
so it's like booking.com airbnb all
these are called ulta
like online travel agencies and of
course it's better if you have direct
bookings because you don't have to pay
the percentage to the online travel
agencies but it's a necessary ebook
because they give you a wider audience
you know better clientele let's say
and then the the premium that they pay
per night is of course you can you can
get the normal
buy to let rent which let's say 500
pounds just just for the second
example fire department a month with a
normal buy to let with a service
accommodation you can get in four days
five days you know yeah it's a
no-brainer
yeah but it's a lot more hands-on so you
need to build systems
for you to be you know completely
handled and that's the point right you
just said it's hands-on
but you need to build systems so that
it's hands-on it can be hands-off
but it's just about setting it up
initially so that if
it's smooth you've got your key safe
you've got it listed properly you've got
a channel manager
yeah um so so what's the kind of
difference in profit then so a normal
buy to let property let's say you buy it
for 150 grand
you rent it out and then on average how
much are your buy to let's make in your
profit
profit about four hundred pounds oh four
five which is not bad you've got 10 of
them
yeah that's four or five grand a month
financial freedom great but
your service accommodation properties
how much is your profit on those
so you're talking about two or three
times that right the net so the profit
yeah so the gross is about three three
thousand pounds and then
let's say just go mean one thousand
pound profit
that's that's the bare minimum and
that's the thing it's not about how many
houses you own it's about how much money
you're making yeah
right which is great also your family as
well you've got a lovely family
it's your daughter's birthday tomorrow
yeah so i appreciate you coming down to
see me we kind of met halfway
you're living in scotland yeah i'm
living in london
such a long drive so we decided to meet
neutrally in newcastle to do the
interview
um um talk to me about your your wife
your family
how how's life changed since you got
into property and started
started and building financial freedom
and passive income yeah man this is
my family is the key of everything i do
you know the main motivation
um well i'm italian as you can see my
wife is mexican we both live in scotland
so it's not a joke
and my two kids were born in scotland so
um for me
family is everything so i had to do
something to make
um our future a better future it's not
that
it's not that was bad it's just i wanted
a better future because we have family
in italy from new mexico we want to
travel so we don't spend money on
you know stupid things it's just travel
food
normal things but we couldn't afford it
with one salary
you know even if i was a university
lecturer and for many the study of the
university lecture
it's a good it's good salary it wasn't
enough for a family of four
so i had to do something yeah so now
um i mean what does an average day look
like for you
well i'm here the the flats or the
apartments are all booked
we have guests saying we have buy to
that field so
as you can see it's completely freedom
yeah you know this is the freedom of
choice we were talking about before
if you don't have that you have to do
something to get it because that allows
you to do
anything in life it's not about money
it's about the choices the money gives
you
yeah um when we met did you know that
you would end up becoming financially
free
i i was hoping to yeah but i didn't know
you know because for me it was a
completely new game a completely
new language i had to learn everything
from scratch yeah now if i did it i mean
i'm 41 now and i did it three and a half
years ago
honestly everybody can do it there's no
age limits there is no
size limits there is no um background
limits yeah you know
i didn't have a rich background but i
did it
i have i had my principles i had my
values yeah and i had my
my inspiration which was my family for
me so
another thing as well is um you know
your
your your heart is to also see other
people win i know you've done some
training
and you've helped a lot of people as
well you've shared openly you've got as
i say you've got a youtube channel
uh you have plans to be a big property
trainer and to help thousands and
thousands of people
um what why is that because i get asked
that question sometimes people say to me
you know if you're making so much money
in property why do you bother to teach
and do youtube and what's that what's
the purpose
and for me it's it's because i want to
yeah having money gives you choices to
do what you want
and i love it so as someone who's become
financially free and has now said you
know what i'm financially free
i don't necessarily i don't necessarily
need to have a job or work or do
anything i could lie to the beach now
with my family and never talk to anybody
else ever again
but you're you're telling me i want to
train and i want to share and i want to
do youtube videos
it'd be interesting because you might
have a few years ago asked me the
question what are you running this
crash course what's the so i'll ask you
what what what's the reason for that
what
where does that desire come from good
question good question does that come
from passion
you know if you if you're financially
you don't do anything you get bored
so you you have the financial freedom uh
because you want to do something else
you want to have that choice you know
and for me teaching has been a passion
i've been a university lecturer i've
been in education for many years
yeah so for me teaching has always been
a passion i love being on stage i love
the energy of the audience
and i love chatting i love sharing
especially because i've been in a
position
like the people i'm teaching to now yeah
and i know that if i did it they can do
it too
and why not you know because you used to
teach
um science yeah and talk about what was
it what did you public health
public health yeah um which which is
great and i know as well as a university
lecturer you said to me that
a lot of lecturers a lot of teachers are
a little bit boring but it doesn't have
to be that way
you know so um you know i believe that
education is is really really important
so
you know i'm really excited to see what
you do
and to see the rippling effect of who
you help and who you can share
what you've done in scotland you know
it's really really really exciting so
um you know massive respect for that
you're a great person
what was the um when you first came to
the crash course
what was it like what happened what
happened
the energy in the room was amazing and
and then i believed
that i could do it so i remember phoning
my wife that time and said
hey olga we can do this no this is
possible and then
after the crash course uh i kept um
studying i kept educating myself um and
then you know
i started to study other strategies as
well not only those that i knew
rent to rent i didn't have a rent rent
by the time you know
i started to investigate about these
options because you were talking a lot
about these options but
then i learned the score transcript
differently and the solutions are a bit
more fuzzy about
but without saying i did manage to get
exchanged with
a completion for uh one of the clients
you know that i source the property for
yeah so it is possible it just takes a
bit more work
yeah and also it's different everywhere
every patch is different
yeah um every strategy is different and
the strategies are a tool box
really so um but but but yes okay so
what's next what can we expect to see
over the next 12 months what what
where do you do you plan on buying more
houses i mean you know what my advice to
you is
but tell us what's next right what's
next i have a few projects in the
pipeline the youtube now is the
is the youtube channel which is a
property launch with you separate you've
been a guest
yeah thank you and is to interview more
property experts to give value to the
communities completely free and that's
that's what i like to do and
i'm training at the moment to be a
mortgage broker and that's something
that i'm going to be
releasing soon and again it makes no
sense yeah to be a mortgage broker
but you want to i want to it was why so
why not
yeah and what about what about on the
actual property side itself property
side
now you um i'm still in the stage where
i'm buying a lot of small
properties uh i know you you advise me
to say you know go go for bigger
deals yeah so it's the same amount of
work but you get more money
um but at the same time i like like
doing you know leveraging leveraging the
money for example if you have 100 runs
rather than by one refurbishing
refinance
i prefer to buy four with a mortgage and
then
wait two years after the uh refer for
the the fixed rate is finished
and then just before the uh two years is
finished then
i do a small refurb like new kitchen new
bathroom whether it's necessary
up the value and then pull the money out
so i think which is great yeah which is
very very similar it's just a slightly
different time score difference so i can
pull the money out plus i have four
years
sorry two years of rent which allowed me
to get more than four
yeah it's smart and you're very smart
with money and you've you've
got a lot of experience and you've and
everybody will find their own
their own way you know their own way of
doing things um
you know you can train 100 people but
but
they'll all end up you know my job isn't
to try and create gingerbread men and to
say everyone's gonna do the exact same
and you've kind of found your niche in
scotland i'm really excited about seeing
you do bigger deals though
i want to see you you know start doing
massive stuff but really really really
excited what would you say
if someone is watching this it's maybe
thinking actually i'm probably not much
dissimilar to how you were four years
ago
you know i haven't got much money maybe
i've got a little bit of equity
but who's really wanting to get their
foot in the door and get started in
property
what would you say your best advice
would be to someone wanting to get
started
another good question uh first of all
money is not scarce
okay so people that think that they have
a limit with money
they have to remove the limit straight
away because money is there you just
need to find a way to get it
yeah and second is you need to define
your destination where you want to go
where you want to be
there's no point in getting to property
if you don't know where you're going
it's like getting to the car
no not putting the gps and says okay
take me somewhere
you're not going anywhere yeah so it's
important to have a business plan you
know
where you're going and then start small
but start
you know i i was reading today a post on
facebook or a 20 years old
guy was saying um i want to get into
property
uh shall i do bigger deals or small
deals first and one person say
start small and say small like three
flats no just as small just everyone
and then once you learn you master it
then you can move to the next one you
can do bigger deals
yeah but there's no point in
overwhelming yourself at the beginning
no i'm a mindset coach so i work a lot
of mindset that's the reason why
i believe that everything is possible
you just need to find the right tool
yeah that's great well that's really
really good advice and
um i'm so happy to see you succeeding
it's been great having dinner took you
out for an italian
italian restaurant today and uh no it's
been such a pleasure to know you and to
see your success
so thank you so much thank you also for
coming on the on the show and sharing
and inspiring other people i know that's
what you're about
and i look forward to maybe doing a part
two in another four years
when you're when you're a billionaire or
something who knows but uh keep up the
great work
thank you very much samuel thank you for
inviting me here you're so welcome
uh i hope you enjoyed that i think
you'll appreciate giuseppe is absolute
legend he's done super super well in
property and now he's coming up to share
to inspire other people
so please please if you enjoyed the
video smash the like button
don't forget to subscribe if you want to
see more videos like this you can see a
playlist of
over a hundred other interviews i've
done similar to this one also don't
forget to
um check out some of the on the road
videos where you get to see me
negotiating crunching deals you can see
a whole playlist up here
and i will look forward to seeing you on
the next video thanks so much see you
next time